let's talk about all of it with CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus he's
gonna help us understand the latest so
we just heard Carter report that the
patient in California was not diagnosed
four days because they were not tested
where are we on the question of testing
and also quarantines what's the latest
well that patient didn't meet the CDC
criteria for testing so obviously the
criteria were wrong and we are now
testing people who present to a hospital
with an unexplained pneumonia the
problem is they're not that many tests
around so when you look at the numbers
and this happened in China we say well
the death rate was two and a half
percent in China it was because they're
only testing people who are really
really sick 81 percent of people who get
this or just have mild symptoms and so
most of them haven't been tested so the
CDC criteria has now been expanded so
that patients like this are tested but
what is the the test and why is it so
specialized so this is an RNA virus you
have to take it you have to convert it
to DNA then you have to amplify it and
see how much DNA is there so it's a
complicated test totally doable but it's
new and so the CDC came up with the
first test there were some issues with
it and the country is slowly getting
used to doing it and it takes a while to
get the results either saying we don't
have enough of these tests Wow the
graphic just said 200 tests in
California we're following eight plus
thousand people they don't equal to me
yeah you know it was so scary David is
that you thought okay if I haven't been
to China which is Ground Zero or been in
contact with anybody from China or any
of the countries that we keep hearing
about Milan but this case in California
I think just took it to a whole
different level so how concerned should
we really be because I now and now I
think people in this country are
thinking oh and oh no who's next and
what symptoms should I be looking for so
these are heroic care should we be these
are heroic doctors who said forget to
CDC right area I am testing this patient
yeah do you really think it's the first
test I mean the first positive in the
country no there are many other people
who have coronavirus and unfortunately
for two weeks or so you can be
symptomatic and you can spread this
virus and so you know think of it this
way in eight million years our genome
the human genome changed 1% through
evolution this virus does it in a day or
two but you have to come in contact with
somebody says it exactly you come in
contact with someone who has it and then
it can spread and the problem is this
bread can happen pretty dramatically is
very easy to spread
the death rate is very low with this
virus most people will survive this
virus but it can spread dramatically so
what we're gonna see very soon or
quarantine I know we have mentioned
earlier new quarantine in California but
they haven't happened yet but there will
be quarantined in this country it's not
if but it's when and where and we're all
gonna have to prepare for it right what
do you do to prepare very simply is you
know company say hey what's our work
from home policy be aware that your
children may have to take school from
home get a week of food dry food in your
house and be ready for this there's no
reason to panic we're all going to do
fine but there's gonna be a new way of
life and we have to prepare for that way
of life how do you know if you should be
tested well if you start to have
symptoms lam that is pulmonary symptoms
of caught a cold etc most of them are
going to be a coffin a cold this time of
year yeah but if they continue to get
worse talk to your doctor about being
tested the test is a swab and as of next
week we should have more and more tests
in the country more testing places in
the country sort of be more commonplace
to do this what do you think about
flying and wearing masks do you think
everybody should be wearing masks to
those mass make a difference mister
first of all I'm here so I flew here and
I am flying home tomorrow so being on a
plane is no different than us talking
here I'm not afraid of flying
yeah mass if you look at Asian culture
you wear a mask when you're six when you
coffee you don't get other people sick
wearing the mask to prevent getting the
virus to me doesn't make a lot of sense
if you're coughing it is a sign of
respect to wear that mask and everyone
in our country should this is a new era
and the ear is carrying not about
yourself but about your community if you
feel ill do not go to work don't send
your kid to school if you have a runny
nose we shouldn't have done that before
but now it's a call for all of us to
work together to be part of the solution
all right thank you David thank you